hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve contains duplicate this is
another problem from the blind 75 list
of questions we've been working on so i
like this problem because it's a good
problem for beginners but there's also
multiple solutions to it that i'd like
to go over in this video so we're given
an array of numbers we want to return
true if there's any value in that list
of numbers that appears at least twice
but maybe it could appear three times or
four times write just at least twice and
we want to return false if there aren't
any values that appear at least twice
basically what that means is that every
value in the array is distinct so let's
take a look at an example we have one
two three and then we have 1 again so of
course this has duplicates right so we
return true and the easiest way we would
be able to detect that is by brute
forcing this so given these numbers the
first thing we do is look at the first
number it's 1. how do we know if this is
a duplicate or not well we'd have to
compare it to every single number in the
rest of the array so that would be a big
o of n time operation just to check if
the first number is a duplicate or not
and then we'd have to do that for every
number then we have to check is the
second number a duplicate how do we know
we have to compare it to every other
number we do the same thing with the
third one and the last one and so since
we're doing it for every number in the
array the overall time complexity is
going to become n squared and by the way
in this case n is just the size of the
input array so the brute force solution
is big o n squared time complexity but
the good thing is we don't need any
extra memory so the memory complexity is
big of one it's definitely not a bad
solution but the question is can we do
better than that and yes we definitely
can a second approach that will help us
is sorting what happens if we took this
array and we sorted it it would look a
little bit different it would look like
this okay but how does sorting help us
well let's think about it if we sort the
input then any duplicates that do exist
in the array and clearly we see that two
duplicates exist at the beginning of the
array they're going to be adjacent so
when we're
trying to detect any duplicates in here
we only have to iterate through the
array once and as we do that we're just
going to be comparing two neighbors in
the array checking if they're duplicates
next we're going to shift our pointers
to the next spot are these duplicates
are these duplicates etc etc until we
finish the entire array in this case we
see that these two adjacent values are
duplicates so we can return true and
what's the time complexity of this well
the one pass is just going to be big o
of n but we know that sorting does take
extra memory or not extra memory it does
take uh extra time complexity and that
time complexity is n log n so that's the
bottleneck in this solution but again we
don't need extra space if you don't
count the space that's used by the
sorting algorithm so in this case we do
have a slightly better solution than
brute force but actually if we use a
little bit extra memory and it's really
a trade-off if we sacrifice space
complexity we can actually achieve
better memory complexity and let me show
you how so suppose we don't sort our
input we're given the default input but
we use extra memory we use a hash set
but what exactly is a hash set gonna do
for us it's gonna allow us to insert
elements into the hash set in big o of
one time but it's also gonna allow us to
check we can ask our hashmap does a
certain value exist we want to know does
this 1 exist in the hashmap well if we
start at the beginning of the array so
far nothing is in our hashmap so a 1
does not exist in our hashmap that means
this 1 is not a duplicate you can see
that this is an improvement over the
brute force previously to determine if
this was a duplicate we had to check
every other value in the array this time
we don't but after we have checked if
this is a duplicate we do have to add it
to our hash set because later on if we
encounter a one like over here then we
determine that this is a duplicate
because we know that there's already a
one in our hash set so next we're gonna
check two two is not a duplicate added
here is three a duplicate nope add it
here one is this a duplicate yep there's
a one over here so we return true this
does contain duplicates and by the way
since each operation was just big o of
one we had to do that for every value in
the input array and we only had to scan
through the list of inputs once the time
complexity is going to be big o of n but
the space complexity we did have to
sacrifice a little bit we have to create
a hash set and the memory that that hash
set will use could be up to the size of
the input array which is n so we do end
up using extra memory but that's not too
bad this is about as efficient as we can
get in terms of time complexity so let's
get into the code now okay so now let's
get into the code so the first thing i'm
going to do is create that hash set in
python you can do that just like this
it's just called a set and then the
simple thing is just going through every
value in the input array nums and
before we end up adding it to our hash
set because remember we want to add
every one of these values to our hash
set just like this but before we even do
that we want to know is n a duplicate
does this value already exist in our
hash set and if it does we know that our
array contains duplicates so we don't
even have to continue through the rest
of the array we can immediately return
true because we found a duplicate but if
it doesn't contain a duplicate we're
going to add that value then iterate
through the rest of the array of nums
and then the loop will exit and then we
can return false to indicate that we did
not find any duplicates in the array now
let's run the code to make sure that it
works and on the left you can see that
yes it does work and it is about as
efficient as we can get so i really hope
that this was helpful if it was please
like and subscribe it supports the
channel a lot consider checking out my
patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching